hey this is really really funny
and also sort of sad
one of the things we've learned about
the
neo-reactionary
republican party some people call it
trumpism some people call it
magga some people
don't talk about it at all and i envy
those people quite frankly um one of the
things we've learned about them is
they will fall for just about any scam
that's presented to them by republicans
by donald trump by don jr by kimberly
guiltfoil whoever right okay they just
they fall for it you say hey we need
your money
because i gotta fix up my private plane
they'll donate if you say i need your
money because i'm going to
uh do ardets and we're going to recount
and
sue and overturn the election and they
just start hemorrhaging money okay they
just start sending the money in
they are that dumb they are that
gullible
one of the things many of you have been
writing to me about recently
is that um you are on you know
republican mailing lists or trump
mailing lists whatever just to kind of
see what's going on and many of you have
written to me that you're getting
hammered with fundraising requests
signed by trump although some of them
aren't from trump's pac some of them are
from the republican senate committee or
the gop
the rnc whatever
and that sometimes they're so frequent
that it's multiple times per hour i've
gotten screenshots of text messages from
viewers showing me that like four times
in an hour they were getting text
messages uh signed by donald trump in
trump's voice asking for money now right
wing
um
what to even call right winger charlie
kirk
thinks trumpists aren't dumb enough to
fall for the fundraising cringe now i
have to give it to charlie kirk and this
clip we're going to look at
kirk correctly identifies that there's
too many fundraising messages going out
he's completely correct about that
but the funny thing is he says
the our people aren't dumb enough to
fall for this no charlie they are dumb
enough to fall for it that's what we've
seen take a look at this do you get some
of these emails
from donald trump or from the nrsc i
need 20 right now by the way it's not
from trump it's from all the consultants
around him and i just i love trump i
defend trump and i just think the people
around him that are sending these emails
are doing such a disservice to donald
trump right
i mean it is a joke it is a mockery i
talk to grassroots people all the time
they say charlie why do i get all these
emails i mean i could show you my text
messages here it is an absolute
insult to our intelligence this is just
over a couple days
it's really not an insult to their
intelligence it's tailored to their
intelligence text messages
trump rally alert have you rsvp'd for
trump's rally in wisconsin no i live in
wisconsin arizona actually
how about this one
don jr my father just called and asked
about you friend he's activated you're
seven times impact for five minutes by
the way i know don and i know that this
stuff is not even being run by them
president so by the way and and notice
that charlie kirk because he doesn't
want to lose access charlie kirk knows
that this is this is
just horror it looks horrible but he
doesn't want to lose access to trump and
don jr and everybody so he insists like
they're not even aware of any of this
stuff so who is it that's doing who has
the authority to send stuff written in
trump and don jr's name trump will
deliver marks at a rager major rally
this next one these are like within five
minutes they're sending them non-stop
offer attached from office of president
trump mar-a-lago okay he's in bedminster
right now
this is your only chance to claim the
end of month seven times impact trump
alert now president trump needs your
support do you have his back 15 minutes
left by the way i've tried my best to
try to tell the trump team to stop
sending these stupid emails and no one
listens to me so i'm gonna have to do it
on the show right you are going to lose
your supporters if you keep on sending
out this unfiltered garbage how about
this one biden and camel are terrified
that you'll click this link camella
camella save america people are not this
dumb okay actually well we have to raise
as much money as we can then how about
you treat your voters with respect right
so listen
the only charlie kirk is completely
correct that this looks absolutely
terrible i mean it's humor it's terri
the number of these pathetic emails we
covered one where it's like
uh
win lunch with trump and in the fine
print it's like trump will not be at the
lunch
it's like they were going to send
lindsey graham or something like that it
was absurd
and a lot of us would say these are
insults to our intelligence but
it seems like a lot of the people that
are that are getting the the stuff
really are that this dumb that's the
reality and case in point you need look
only after the 2020 election they were
fundraising every 10 minutes for audits
and legal challenges and overturn and
all this stuff and you look down at the
fine print and it would say 50 60 75 i
think in one case percent of each dollar
donated
could actually would actually be used
to pay off trump's campaign debt or to
generally fund i don't remember if at
the time it was the save america pac or
whatever else and i i think it's also
possible that charlie kirk is playing
this as
this isn't effective this will alienate
voters and it is too much and you know
it's an insult to people's intelligence
charlie kirk runs an organization that
also to some degree depends on donations
for many of the same people and it
wouldn't shock me if charlie kirk is
aware that the pie is being sliced into
so many pieces
that
the donations the turning point may also
uh be declining dramatically i mean even
the trumpist donations i don't know
what's going on with turning points
fundraising to be clear
but the trump donations go there's
trump's pac there's the rnc there's the
republican senate campaign committee and
all these different things all of these
maga people with their hands out for the
grift and it seems like they're all kind
of getting hurt and i would if a
republican is complaining about another
republican
the first thought that should occur to
you is
do they have a personal interest in this
are they personally being hurt by what
they're criticizing and when it comes to
charlie kirk and turning point usa
it's completely plausible that that's
what's going on we'll have this clip
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show make sure you're
following us there
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the u.s alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 made from bamboo a bamboo
stock keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one american uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
soft toilet paper real paper loves the
david pakman show they're giving my
audience thirty percent off your first
order and free shipping when you go to
real paper dot com slash pacman and use
the code pacman at checkout the link is
down below